thank you so much for calling vip zappos
zappos.com one of fortune magazine's top
10
best companies to work for i'll be happy
to look into that for you and who am i
speaking with today
the multi-million dollar company based
in henderson
is the brainchild of entrepreneur tony
shea do you consider yourself ambitious
at all um i guess i wouldn't say
ambitious more probably just the type of
person that gets bored easily
shea says his passion for business
didn't start with selling shoes
but earthworms bought a bunch of them
and thought i could grow them and
produce more worms but that didn't quite
work out they all escaped
when the worm business didn't hit pay
dirt he moved on
there's the lemonade stand there's this
small mail order
button business where i would make the
buttons that people pin on
after graduating from harvard shea and
his roommate created
linkexchange.com we grew that to about
100 or so people and then ended up
selling the company to
microsoft two and a half years later for
a whopping
265 million dollars eventually using
that money to invest in a small.com
that sold shoes were you a big shoe guy
or something at all uh
no not at all i i mean i'm still not
today this is where our ceo tony shea
sits
zappos became so popular amazon.com
bought it for 1.2 billion
making shea even richer he always
believes regardless of who he meets or
what they do
that there's something that he can learn
from them shea's longtime friend and cfo
fred mosler
says tony never wanted the big corner
office
so today he has a cubicle tony's very
very humble and how he approaches his
life he's achieved a lot
and sums it all in a book he titled
delivering happiness
it's really about toughing through the
hard moments shea says the secret to his
success
can be achieved in three words never
give up persistence and resilience play
a big role
and i think a lot of people actually do
give up
too early that ambitious kid who started
with
worms never gave up and that's his key
to delivering happiness